let's go
next where are we going next let's go to
alex from new york alex welcome
hi david hi
so i know we're looking ahead at the 22
2022 midterms but i just wanted to ask
about 2024 so because i know we've got
mixed signals about joe biden running
for re-election yes uh what is the
possibility do you think he could beat
trump and do you think he'll run for
re-election too early to say and i don't
think he's going to run for re-election
on whether he could beat trump i mean
is trump under indictment
is trump still popular with republicans
when the time comes i just think it's an
empirical question we don't have the
answer to
my opinion is that joe biden is not
going to run for re-election i know that
that's controversial among my audience
but i don't i don't believe biden will
run for re-election
what reasons do you have for that i
think he's just not interested in it i
think that uh
he was
so sort of he's a transitional president
hopefully out of trumpism i think his
age is a factor i just don't know that
uh it's something that is of interest to
him although i have to say with the
resurgence that the by the rebirth that
the biden administration has had in the
last two months i'm feeling less
confident about that but i still think
if you give me just like an even odds
bet right now i say biden does not run i
would be glad to be wrong
all right well thank you david thank you
there's alex from new york with a very
precise question just a reminder if
you're holding on to chat with me
if your name
in the waiting lobby is anything other
than your name and where you are calling
from you will not be called on so people
who have nicknames listed people who are
using parentheses to get to the top of
the list all these different things you
will not be called on the only format
that is valid is for example mike from
baiko mike is next mike what is is bako
how it's pronounced i've never heard of
that
uh it's actually bakersfield oh it's
just like a nickname for bakersfield i
did not know that mike from bakersfield
welcome
thank you yeah actually a big fan um
yeah so my question would be um how um
what is your favorite
okay
what is my favorite what
and they're gone all right very good man
we are we are really struggling with
some of these calls today let's go next
to kevin from san diego california since
we dropped a call from bakersfield i
figure we'll go near nearby what's going
on there kevin you know san diego is
clearly a much superior place to
bakersfield we at least pick up the
calls and i don't think i'm going to
leave anytime soon in my experience i
have to agree with you no offense to
people from bakersfield but having been
to both i have to say my preference is
san diego but no offense to anybody
well yeah no that's very uh very
diplomatic take if you dated thank you
um i wanted to go a little bit away from
uh politics right now i wanted to know
um do you have a particular like workout
routine or otherwise uh you know way to
stay in shape
well i basically will alternate cardio
and um
uh weight training essentially uh for
cardio i like running and biking
and then in terms of weight training you
know i'll find some circuits online and
then like when i was going to the gym
before the pandemic i would do them
there uh but then you know during the
painting
yeah are you still out of the gym i'm
still out of the gym but you know i'm
i'm starting to look at going back
because with my schedule i'd be i just
you know i used to get colds all the
time i haven't had a cold in so long and
i think part of it is
spending time at the gym is a great
place to get yourself a cold you know
and um i think if i went back i would be
able to go at a time that it's very very
quiet
and i think it might be a good thing
there's just so much more equipment you
know
yeah there is a lot going on at the gym
it's
uh it's worth it for
more detail things if you're kind of
basic on whatever you're doing like you
can just lift some weights or have like
a you know oh in terms of the thing do
you have like a stationary bicycle or
treadmill or something or do you like
actually run outside i run outside i
bike outside
all right well that's the way to do it
it really is it really is
uh that's about it david should i be
taking some kind of protein powder do
you think or am i probably okay uh i
mean i'm not an expert on any of these
kind of things i think it's like
basically you can get really detailed on
the things that you're doing with any
kind of fitness stuff but
um if you are at the level where you're
not seeing yourself like improve a lot
over what you're doing regularly you can
always add something else so like
protein powder at that point is probably
a good idea but if you're just kind of
if you're fine where you are you
probably don't need it yeah no i'm not
going to use any protein powder i was
just curious your opinion oh okay well
honey
that's fair i mean you did
not take my opinion on that
taco place that you said last time you
said in san diego i believe it's called
is it posto
i it was something like that but it
looked like fancy and tasty and i wanted
to try there and i couldn't remember
exactly what it was and yeah oh no
i believe it's
the brisket taco is hard to beat
if you're ever in san diego again i
highly recommend you go to tacos el
gordo in national city okay that is is
way less fancy of a place but the
autobahn tacos are to die for they're
amazing beautiful all right i appreciate
the recommendation
all right
all right take care very good uh very
very sub really like meaty calls today